As I hinted at in the last lesson, your boss really likes cats.
They want even more cats.
In fact, they want Cat Clicker Premium.
Now obviously, you'll run out of screen space if you add too many more,
so your boss wants you to build a list of cats on the side.
And when you choose a cat from that list, the cat is displayed in the cat area.
That will mean quite a few changes to your application.
You'll need to find a way to build a list of cats.
You'll need to add selection functionality to the list.
You'll need to display the correct cat when the list items are clicked, and
of course, you'll need to keep each cat's number separate and accurate.
I'll provide you with an official spec sheet for
the new application in a second.
And my advice to you is the same.
Try not to repeat yourself, and make sure that you choose some cute pictures of
cats so they can comfort and console you if you feel frustrated.
After this step, we'll go over the code together and
we'll start talking about some useful organizational techniques for
resolving some of the problems you're likely running into.